you
everyone it's Jerry amount chest calms
tactics trainer and I'm gonna work my
way through three puzzles and just share
my train of thought along the way well I
feel like I've seen this puzzle before
what is the story with this oho oh this
is an endgame study I don't know if I've
covered it in a video but I see the
solution well it's helpful knowing these
little stalemate resources when it comes
time for these puzzles why cannot win
this
why needs to draw and the way forward is
not to go pawn hunting in fact you're
not even guaranteed to get this guy rook
here there's rook e8 and we got three
connected passed pawns the idea here is
to trap your own king I've covered one
of these actually what was probably
helpful is covering one of these endgame
studies and the cool chess puzzles
playlist or some idea where the bishop
was actually involved but black is
controlling a lot of squares over here
if our king is on a five in our pond is
on a four we run out of moves
so after rook takes rook King takes rook
1 2 3 4 and we're in stalemate rook
takes rook King takes rook King b3h for
King a 4 h3 King a 5 H 2 a 4 pick your
favorite move we're in stalemate
I guess the maybe the best try for black
but they're not going to be in time no
it's gonna be as a draw but if you don't
capture the rook after rip take struck
and I don't know push your f pawn this
rook is really fast to pick up the a
pond and then sneak around to stop the H
upon a time so black has to capture back
here and then we go for what's known as
a self stalemate seen many of these
types of ideas and endgame studies and
that's what we have on board right here
problem solved blacks on move but
regardless of what blacks next move is
stalemate draw on board interesting
start let's see about puzzle 2
okay team black
Oh what an adjustment this one is well
here's a very important mating idea to
be familiar with take on h2 King takes
rook h8 queen block we take the Queen we
give made on h1 night and day last
puzzle to this one a very important
mating idea to be familiar with not so
much that stalemate resource in first
puzzle but yep king move rook h1 but
that's as far as they take it with this
one let's try one last one team black ok
what is the solution to this well black
is up a piece up a night a full night
five pawns versus five white is
vulnerable on the back rank let's not
forget this I'm thinking it's a knight
move but where - exactly
well if we play let's say Knight c4
it's attacks the Queen Knight c4 allows
what Knight c4 allows white to take the
rook and on Queen takes rook Queen takes
rook is hitting with check we don't have
time to take advantage of the back rank
but it's likely factors in hmm oh you
know what it might be
no let me just share what I thought for
a moment I thought of attacking the
Queen from a different square I have 7
and I thought after Knight f7 rook takes
for a queen takes rook
oh that maybe is it we could play King
h7 this is what I was thinking first
though Knight f7 Knight f7 rook takes
rook Queen takes rook we allow our rook
to be captured with check no that's not
working after King h7 yeah we're
attacking the rook but the rook just
comes all the way back to defend me
that's silly
why did I even devote a second to that
alright let's try something else what
else is there
well we're up a beast but we're ready to
lose him right back
is it even a night move well
maybe it's night here so that rook queen
takes rook isn't hitting with check
that might be it
my concern is well there's rook e8
because we don't have as much control on
the back rank anymore
well I'm running out of ideas here for
Canada moose it's now fun
okay it has to be a knight move
otherwise we just lose the knight back
and how could that be a good thing
Knights e4 rook takes rook if Knight
takes Queen oh this is the answer
Knights e4 rook takes rook Knight takes
Queen
[Music]
after rook takes Queen we recapture the
rook and if they get the knight back we
give me my only concern is ah I'm just
noticing one other detail here the key
idea here is to attack the Queen and
both of these moves you know Knight f7
Knight see for both attack the Queen but
what is the key difference because in
the end if in both cases Knight f7 and
rook c4 if rook takes rook is played
we're taking the Queen who cares what
square the knight came from but there's
a different idea available to white that
I am only now seeing because I'm
questioning Knight f7 and Knight C form
there is a threat rook takes pawn that
maybe I should have seen right out of
the gates knight on f7 defends h6 this
h6 pawn is unprotected currently because
g7 is pinned therefore its Knight f7 to
not only attack the queen but defend
against rook takes pawn
so if Knight f7 rook takes pawn we can
take on h6 we're winning a rook for upon
if rip takes rook only at that point do
we recapture yes we can allow Queen
takes rook but by that point we have a
knight and queen versus Queen position
that must be it let's see what black
does goes in for this we take the Queen
take the rook puzzle solved puzzle
solved okay well an interesting group of
three certainly that first one getting
thrown or thrown in in game study and
yeah a nice group of three I think
an important mating sequence in the
second one and a little bit of
calculation working out the details the
difference is between two moves Knight
c4 versus f7 in this case and exploiting
where team white in this case is weak
and that is on the back rank
okay well as usual feel free to share
how you did with these three in the
comments section below
and I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you
[Music]